human beings are really dangerous to the
surface of Mars let's say life did exist
on the surface of Mars would it be able
to withstand the bacteria the viruses
all of the bad things that we have on
earth without having the protection
because it's never seen it before so we
have to protect Mars against the Box not
to freak you out or anything the other
thing is we want to make sure that we
don't bring our stuff there and then
falsely say oh there's life on the
planet when we actually brought it so
what's going on behind me in the
cleanroom is they're actually building
the hardware the instrument that's gonna
go to space the dirtiest thing in the
cleanroom is the human beings our hair
comes off there's flakes of skin lots of
bad stuff that looks like life -
detection instruments that we might be
able to fly a long time ago we thought
we've found life on the moon and when we
actually investigated the bacteria that
we saw growing it actually happened
because somebody sneezed on a lens of a
camera almost every morning when we come
into the cleanroom were wiping down the
spacecraft every evening before we leave
we wipe down the spacecraft we actually
bake it out in a vacuum to drive off a
lot of the biological material and the
spacecraft has to have a certain number
of spores or we can't fly you have to
clean it again
you know is there a chance we'll find
life on the surface of Mars the answer
is actually yes it's quite possible we
will here on earth everywhere we find
water we find life and now that we know
that Mars was once a very liquid wet
place it's most probable that we farming
now that's my opinion and if we found
that life what I would really be ashamed
to say is that we did something bad to
it
can you imagine being able to say that
life is not unique
if you have an entire planet to explore
where do you go we will learn something
wherever we are but what is the one site
that will tell us their most about Mars